there's a scene in the movie where you
you wear a leotard and a lot of actors
get very self-conscious about their
bodies beforehand
well hazard to guess you do not is that
fair to say not only do I know but that
the sad part of the scene you're talking
about is I was I was looking really
skinny for me that period of time uh-huh
and in fact I had dropped about 10 to 15
pounds okay uh but you know what it just
doesn't still doesn't work yeah well
this is you at a low weight for you be
in pretty darn good shape did you walk
around like check this out is here
here's where we are now okay there's
okay yeah there's um so thank you for
that thank you
let's did you get a good shot yeah every
yeah there's no booth here it's just a
zoom but yes we we saw all of that and
it was fantastic if you put on a some
weight during this period of time I find
it extremely hard to yes tonight I have
put on some weight yeah I kept the
weight out of my face
no you still look yeah but good lines
yeah a way of getting fat out of my face
which I do at home
oh using a rubber tube and a suction
device and a sterilized razor blade that
keeps me looking it keeps a joke well
but I'm a bloated monster I would say
from mid chest down yeah yep a bloated
parody of a human being ah yeah
anyway yeah you look like you're about
to cry so it's gonna give you a moment
what are you gonna do you know what I
really like I really like that your
father in this film is portrayed by
Pierce Brosnan it takes some serious
balls to cast the handsomest man in the
world as your father right
the total dick move literally makes no
sense he's very funny
he's very funny he's so funny and you
know he he is like one of those people
who's kind of a you know like a perfect
human being like and you know the
ultimate dinner party guests so gracious
and kind and humorous stories and there
is a scene in the movie where he kind of
gives me a I've kind of given up my
dream and I'm gonna just follow in his
footsteps he's a fisherman our family
has been a long line of fishermen and
I've were on the boat and he kind of
gives me this speech to you know go back
and and and go back to the contest and
and do what I was you know put on earth
to do well the day we happen to be
filming I don't it was it was just we
had to film on that day and there were
five to six foot swells and we're
literally shooting on this boat
and people were getting sick and not
hiding it and and there's Pierce just
first of all looking so dashing in a
fisherman's outfit I don't know how you
do that number one right number two not
seasick at all just in between takes
while crew people are throwing up
violently on the side of the boat and
there he is just taking selfies and his
aviator sunglasses just looking perfect
yeah we finally got to to the to the
dock after he came off the boat he was
like that was a day so I I think that
was a positive statement well we have a
clip here from Eurovision Song Contest
as the story of fire saga I don't know
what the what's you believe this is this
is Rachel McAdams who plays secret my
bandmate this is this is before us
getting ready to go onstage for the
Icelandic singing contest this is to the
chance to represent Iceland right in
Eurovision this is like the semi
semifinals just two files and this is
our backstage prep okay let's take a
look at this clip from Eurovision Song
Contest the story of fire saga you know
that a song and Icelandic would never
win Eurovision song I know I know I'm
being silly but I'm just I'm just
anxious it's really a dream come true
yes no what are you doing
I just wanted my ding dong to look
bigger than what is really there should
I draw attention to my groin area as
well now you get it yeah I do a classic
camel okay he's never out of style looks
good
and we're back wasn't that pretty cool
pretty cool but I hope that was the
right setup
if not we can I think given under the
circumstances I'm in an abandoned
theater
you're clearly managing a construction
site I think we're doing pretty well all
things considered I gotta have a crane
by Tuesday there yeah it's a really good
thing you're there